so this is machine learning
infrastructure at stripe going to talk
about sort of how we kind of bridge the
gap between scikit-learn and Python is
the JVM I'm not going to actually talk
much about the modeling side I'm not
going to talk too much about feature gen
side I'm more going to talk about like
how we go from like I have a model I've
trained it I want to get this thing into
the pre-rendered production sort of what
are some of the things that we do to do
that so hi I'm Rob story I'm on the
machine learning infrastructure team at
stripe that's my really weird twitter
handle if you want to follow me on
Twitter so a lot of you might be
familiar with stripe or might use stripe
but for those of you don't essentially
the communication folks say when I talk
to people I should say so I stripe is a
software platform for running an
internet business a lot of you probably
know of us is like a payments platform
right so if you want to sell some things
like build a website and sell some stuff
you can accept credit cards through
stripe we also provide ways to like have
really complex flows like that right so
we can do subscription subscriptions we
have a product called connect which is
like marketplaces right so if you're
lyft and you say have a driver and I
have a writer and I want the writer to
be able to send money to the driver but
I don't actually want to facilitate any
of that like I don't want to deal with
the money we have things to say all
right well with these marketplace aleut
like things you can actually send money
from one person to the other and not
have to have a middleman the reason I
like to say we're a software platform
running internet business is because we
have things like radar look let's people
set their own progress we have a new
thing called Atlas that lets people from
outside the US and corporate companies
in the US and like to get set up with a
bank account and like a c-corp and all
that so if you have to start up a
website and you want accept payments we
can probably handle it so I start all of
my talks to serve like a leading
question and the leading question I
think it's important for every business
to ask you like why do I need machine
learning like why like why does machine
learning exist at stripe
what do we use it for so most of what we
use it for is fraud so I say merge had
fraud here like merchants is sort of a
jargony term merchants are our customers
either these are the people like you
that would sign up to use stripe use the
platform unfortunately we have people
who sign up for stripe just to defraud
us of money right so they're like I'm
going to sign up for straight
steal a bunch of money from straight so
the trick is that we need to reject
those account applications before a
before they get through B we'd really
like to reject them before a risk
analyst has to look at it right because
we get a lot of applications every day
including some applications that are
just people trying to defraud us that
are automated we'd really like to OTO
reject those before like human set of
eyeballs has to look at it just for like
scaling issues there's also a second
type of fraud I don't I don't really
want to call it fraud but it does have
to do with merchants it's someone trying
to sign up for stripe that doesn't meet
like our Terms of Service so there are
some things that we cannot sell or that
we cannot process payments for and a lot
of those restrictions in the bank so
like we can't sell guns we can't sell
drugs despite them becoming legal and
supports in certain parts of the US
there's just some things that our
banking partners say we cannot do so
here's an example of someone that's
tried to sign up for a stripe account
with the intent of defrauding us right
they're like oh I'm going to make a
website that has like literally a single
product on it like garden hose wheel so
this is an example of like an actual
fraudster saying I'm going to make this
like dubious thing to try to defraud the
company so the second type is
transaction fraud and some of you here
might have actually like been victims of
transaction brought in the past so just
observers talked about this this morning
he said he started his Korean
transaction fraud this is the sort of
thing that we're doing where it's like
the business using stripe is legitimate
but someone is someone that like charges
are being made on the businesses account
that are not authorized by the
cardholder so if you've ever had like
your credit card or debit card numbers
stolen
that's the qualifies a transaction fraud
right like someone buys 500 credit card
numbers and tries to buy a bunch of
stuff and stuff on stripe before the
cardholder notices so we would really
like to stop all of that theoretically
but it's really tricky because if you
think about if you think about like the
typical confusing confusion matrix and
like precision and recall false
positives are bad because we're blocking
legitimate charges it turns out that our
customers really don't like that only
block legitimate charges false negatives
are bad because um you know it's fraud
right people are actually stealing money
so we have to actually be really careful
about balancing the two so the third
type of MLS or do we do at stripe is
like support tools there's a smiley face
here so this is a lot of like text
modeling right
we're like for an agent who has to
answer support ticket we provide like we
make suggestions for how to answer that
ticket or like categorize tickets right
so they can work through the backlog and
the happy face is there because like
happy agents happy customers right the
faster that our customer service agents
can work through that stuff the better
so I'm going to first start with like
the serialization piece and I think it
might be helpful to just give a very
high-level overview of what it like
stripes is like very top-down
infrastructure looks like for serving
your model so we have like the internet
then we have the stripe API that's all
in Ruby so let's say a transaction comes
in we go fetch some features from a
database we send the request with some
of those features so those are like live
features over to our scoring service
this is in Scala we fetched some more
features from summing bird this is sort
of like a batch processing it's like
it's half bad chap online that's doing
counts and that sort of thing if the
model hasn't been loaded from s3 already
we load the model from s3 we score the
prediction and send it back and then our
folks who like our ml engineers who are
doing all the training so they're like
on ec2 on some giant training box and
this is in scikit-learn so they're
training things in Python sending those
models to s3 also fetching the features
for the things are training from s3 so
this is like a very rough overview of
how machine learning happens at stripe
all right so right now we're going to do
a terrifying thing because I hate doing
live demos but we're going to try it
anyway which is my cursor on ok we're
going to ship a model to production
right now it's happening all right I
need that zoning audience participation
I need I need three birds three birds
preferably not too long please but what
was that all right
Kestrel eagle I could crow all right in
both crow all right I need three planets
I knew it I knew it I know it when I did
this demo when I was practicing to him I
put blue in there without thinking about
it one more births all right done I need
a three foods voila
tako all right perfect no no no no
shorter shorter cheese and pizza done
even though beat cheese goes on pizza
that's okay
all right so all right so this is
basically we're going to say all right
so we have a bird flying on a planet
eating some sort of food how far can
that bird fly right so what you should
note here is that most of this stuff
looks like the typical scikit-learn that
you've seen before so we're generating
this fake data set we have a data frame
we have a series we have this thing
called multi column label encoder that
is just your like regular label encoder
that works with a data frame right so
it's like a label encoder that works on
every column of the data frame random
forest a dresser you might have seen
that before
pipeline it's just a normal cycle urn
pipeline like no weird stuff going on
then you see this sort of weird thing
called make serializable that's going to
be the bulk of what we talked about you
can see that we the PI data 2017 crowd
own this model which is great and we can
fit the model so let's see if I can copy
paste this into I know GT cube cube all
right so we fit it cool now we need an
observation let's go with a crow that
eats pizza oh no a pizza all right Pluto
the crows it eats Pizza on Pluto Planet
Pizza all right so we have an
observation this is all still in
scikit-learn land all right it can fly
538 bird units whatever whatever unit
you want to send that okay so cool let's
do this thing called to contentment hash
which is another thing you probably
haven't seen before that we're going to
talk about so this has to call out to
the JVM so it's like cranking cranking
in the meantime we'll go look at these
functions so what these two functions
are doing is basically calling out for
our scoring service I needed to obscure
like the actual host name of the scoring
service and I needed to filter some of
the results because things like test
three buckets and things like that come
back with it
it's probably not good to show on the
and a presentation that's being recorded
so let's copy and paste these into here
so sweet we have two functions we had a
model ID cool we have a model ID so we
have this big hash that represents an
immutable model to lit this NS three now
so in theory we can score this right now
so let's get the model the model ID so
we cool so if we just like fetch some
model data we can see these are features
these are the features we gave it the
model type is this simple bonsai
regression forest we'll talk about
bonsai in a little bit as well the model
name is this giant hash of a thing and
then we all of us in this room on this
model so sweet this is working so far
this is going great
all right so we're going to get a
prediction we have a model ID what was
it before so it was like we called
projects 538 bird units right and that
was a crow that ate pizza
on Mars so it's a crow that eats a Pluto
whoo-hoo it's pizza on Pluto and I hope
we get the same thing
sweet 538 bird units so this all
actually happened like in stripes
infrastructure right now like this is
this is a model that if for some reason
our ml engineers are like we really need
to know about this bird pizza flute or
thing like they could load this model
and it's like it's living in the
infrastructure right now so good job
team we all just shipped a model to
production so awesome let's talk about
the pieces of that that sort of made
this whole flow possible so the first
one is this makes serializable things so
we need to take this pipeline and we
need to make it serializable so this is
the entire body of the make serializable
function there's not much into it so
this registry that make serializable is
basically looking in this registry for
the serializer that we need right so we
take this random forest regressor and we
have a little registry and it says
alright do I have a serializer for the
random forest regressor yes awesome I
have a serializer let's take this
serializer and do the serializable
wrappered thing so what is this
serializable wrapper thing doing well
the serializable wrapper is actually a
very very very thin wrapper around like
just the existing scikit-learn stuff so
part of the power of scikit-learn is
that them they really like make their
they make all of their classes and that
sort of thing very extendable so if you
look at this decorator this if delegate
has a method decorator this is all
scikit-learn machinery right this is
basically saying all right transform i'm
delegate it to the underlying estimator
this basically makes like has a door
work there's some weird stuff going on
but this is basically showing like what
we're doing is building this thin
wrapper around scikit-learn existing
scikit-learn machinery that led us like
have some other behavior so what other
behavior do we need well our scoring
service is written in scala which we
talked about earlier that scoring
service get to feature hash that's just
key value pairs right it's just a map or
a dictionary of key value pairs so one
important thing is this goes through is
that we actually keep track with a data
frame which we require so you see will
actually throw an error here if you
don't have a data frame all of our ml
engineers and data scientists work with
data frames hundred percent all the way
through we use the data frame columns to
say all right these are our feature
names we need to keep track of those as
we go through right because we actually
need to serialize the feature names as
we as we move through this and then we
do this fit with feature name thing
which is just fitting but keeping the
feature names on the class so that we
can serialize it later so this is all
just really thin wrappers so that we can
keep track of feature names as like part
of the data frame as we go through so
this just a little bit of how we do it
but as an ml engineer like you don't
really care you what if you just want to
ship a new model type right you're like
I don't want to use a random force
aggressor I want to use SVM or something
like that and I need to build a
serializer for it like what does that
take oh I want to like not model type
but what if I want to build a new
encoder right so let's say that you want
to build like a new like imputation
thing really I want to build a dumb as
possible imputation thing I want to fill
all missing values with like a single
value it's like negative one great so
this is basically all it takes this is
like the Macan this is like the
machinery in our serialization which is
pretty simple so
we have this serialize function right we
require that you get some bytes right
and it doesn't have to be jason it can
be anything any bytes all all that
matters is we get some bytes so all this
is JSON the bytes is just like UTF
encoded JSON so we have some features
and we have a value and then we build
this feature encoder thing and the
feature encoder we require a few things
so require the name of the encoder this
is so the scala service knows oh this is
the fill missing encoder or the type of
the encoder rather name is optional but
you could apply a name to this actual
encoder we require this pile of bytes
and then an extension so I go away this
is a JSON encoder great all right well
we just talked about random force
aggressor this is the entirety of the
serializer for the random forest
regressor right so we have to go in to
the scikit-learn estimator and like dig
out the guts of this thing and I'll talk
about that in a second
and then we serialize this to this thing
we call bonsai and then we say all right
it is a simple bonsai regression forest
we have this pile of bytes and we have a
bonsai file type quick aside wait what
is this bonsai thing that is weird there
are many ml things named bonsai it turns
out we also have an ml thing named
bonsai but it's an open source ml thing
that you can use if you'd like
basically it's compressed tree so one of
my co-workers Tom roses like very clever
library to compress trees previously our
trees were in yellow there's a lot of
memory overhead and using that so it's a
skylit Scala library that we actually
shell out to from Python to compress
this trees we get this little dot bonsai
file this nice little file and that's
bonsai you can go take a look at this
right now along Scala all open source so
that's bonsai aside over I talked about
diving into the guts of this thing so we
need to extract the structure of these
scikit-learn estimators out so this is
us extracting the structure of the
decision tree regressor right so this
works on scikit-learn version something
point something something the problem
with this is this kind of thing is like
brittle to version changes right I'm
actually pretty sure that the next
version scikit-learn breaks something in
here in some way because I tried it
recently
so this is the downside of like reaching
into the actual object since I could
learn and trying to like build a
serializer from them is without like an
official API it's super brittle to
version changes and changes between
scikit-learn versions because like they
don't make guarantees about internal api
and they shouldn't right but that does
mean that this sort of thing can break
between versions so we went over that
our models and our encoders all know how
to serialize themselves right so we just
went through the code we say an encoder
has a serialized method and those how to
serialize itself into some sort of
encoder or model type and some bytes and
some some extension so then we do this
weird thing called to contentment hash
so we're clearly hashing something right
so what are we hash Inc we're hashing
this thing that we call a model package
so there's actually not a whole lot to
the model package so when we shipped our
model live to production we had an
encoder so we basically we had this
model package with an encoder and we had
our model the encoder type was a
categorical encoder that's what we did
with the label encoder the model type
was this regression forest and basically
this package there's a there's not much
to it so there's sort of this metadata
file that says okay this is our encoder
this is the encoder name this is the
model this is the model name this is who
owns it in this in this file that we end
up zipping up this is what label encoder
Jason looks like right label encoded
values it's exactly these aren't the
exact ones we use these the ones I use
when I first tried this thing but same
thing right we have that bonzai file
which is looks like that right so giant
giant pile of bytes so so we have this
model package we have these files we
have this metadata file and then we zip
it so we have a zip file and we sent it
to s3 and contentment so we say to
contentment hash games contentment is a
little library that uses s3 is like a
Content address store right and so the
nice thing about content addressing is
if we know the hash for this thing then
we know where it lives right so we call
to contentment hash we have this hash
this is like the immutable snapshot of
this model
because remember we hashed like the
whole thing we have the encoders JSON we
have the model as either JSON or the
spawns I thing we hashed the whole model
package so we have an immutable snapshot
of this thing in time if anything in
there changes that has changes and we
have a totally new model in s3 right so
if we know attach we know exactly which
model that we just built so that's great
like immutability in this case is very
powerful so great so we have this model
that lives in s3 well I you know how do
I actually promote it to production
right like we have it in s3 and it's
great but and I can actually load a
prediction and like score the model but
how do I tell the production service
like hey I need that model like I want
that model to be my production model
right so we have this thing called model
deployers like I mean you know does what
it says on the tin right so we go from
like having so basically if you look at
if you look at like the route what we
did before is we called like slash model
flash the big shot of the model ID in
prediction we go to that from having a
tag and basically a tag is a pointer to
a model ID right and the nice thing
actually go forward one so the nice
thing about tags here is that like you
can advance to tag forward right so we
actually have an internal page it
basically looks like this so we have
like this model was deployed at this
time and the tag pointed to this ID
right and this model deployed at this
time in the tag point is the model ID
it's basically a history of our deploys
for models but the nice thing is you can
build tooling that looks like this
around that deployment to say alright I
want to deploy my transaction fraud
model to production I want to deploy
this model what it does is it basically
like swaps out the pointer underneath
right so now the transactions broad
production tag points at that model the
nice thing is though if you like ship
this model to production you're like oh
no I've made a huge mistake right
something is clearly going wrong you can
run this command it will give you the
whole history of models you've ever run
and you can just like say use the last
one like rollback so what this does is
it lets you move shipping models to
production in the same way that you like
you ship a service to production right
let's you go from just like sort of be
like alright we're going to overwrite
the old one that
having a history of deploys and like
feeling better about your deployment not
as scary right in the same ways you want
to ship services in like a not scary way
that you can roll back you want to be
able to ship models in the same way as
well so that's great the like still hot
swapping these models on the fly into
production like sounds scary what if I
actually want to give it a trial run
like I'd really like to score a couple
models side by side before I decide to
put this one into production so this
uses this thing we call shadow models
like shadow I don't know what we call I
don't know why they call the shadow
models it's a cool name where basically
we have this model hierarchy right so we
have a model that fans out to multiple
other models so if the prediction
service calls this model it'll actually
call it'll actually fan out that request
to these three models return all the
predictions and then either aggregate
them or just log them right and so we
have this shadow sir we have essentially
have a service that runs in parallel for
candidate models where we can fan out to
a bunch of candidates log all their
responses and say okay like is one of
these actually ready to go in their
production and then we have tooling
around that that's the same sort of
thing as I showed before right so you
can add a model to shadow you can pull
models out of shadow and this is
happening really often with our ml
engineers just like putting putting
candidate models in shadow seeing how
they fare pulling them out or and or
promoting them to production so talked a
lot about the Python side haven't talked
too much about the JVM bit and some of
you might be wondering great can you
like give me a turnkey solution to like
can you open-source the Python thing and
then hat what what Java things do you
use the bad news is we actually
implement everything on the Scala side
including the encoders so the training
is actually the really hard part right
doing the actual like evaluation like
something like a linear model pretty
straightforward right all you have is a
couple hyper parameters that sort of
thing the evaluation is like much easier
than the training side so you know
implementing an encoder I think this is
yeah this is our category encoder in
scholarly doesn't take that long it
takes a couple days so we've basically
implemented everything on the scholar
side ourselves I'd be interested in
hearing after the talk if any of you
have any like
open source java or scala projects that
you're using to do the sort of thing but
basically like we've got trees and
linear regressions and that sort of
thing all implemented on the Scala side
some components of this are open source
already mostly tree things so I talked
about bonsai the other tree thing like
we have a library called brushfire
that's basically like distributed
decision tree ensemble learning this is
all of the random forest stuff that we
do and it is all open source so like our
service is calling into these libraries
to build up these random forests that we
use in production I just wanted to put
this slide up here as an example of like
the serialization and scikit-learn like
story is kind of fractured right now
SPARC uses PMML there was a talk
yesterday from the HomeAway folks they
also use PMML for those of you who don't
know apple core ml when they were when
they announced a core amel library they
sort of quietly also released a python
library that this scikit-learn to
protobuf serialization library I think
if it existed a couple years ago our
team probably would have ended up using
it but we ended up sort of rolling our
own stuff it's mostly JSON we talked
about the bonsai thing I'm also
interested from hearing from folks about
weather so you think about it we have
this Python library that serializes
things we have these Scala sides which
does all the evaluation and predictions
I feel like there's not a lot of value
in open sourcing the Python side is also
open sourcing the scala side that can
read these serialize models and encoders
and actually serve the predictions but
I've sort of seen that in the past like
there hasn't been a ton of success and
like open sourcing these giant systems
right because usually you'll have
requirements especially around feature
fetching that that system does not does
not solve so it's kind of tricky so
quick talk that's basically it happy to
answer any questions that is you know
that is sort of like the high-level
overview of how we you know put machine
learning into production at stripe so
thank you all questions
[Applause]
my mother is not here so I want to find
this microphone works you can just yell
out your questions yep yeah that's a
good question the answer is that like
the ml and data science folks like
really like working in scikit-learn like
a lot because it gives them I mean like
is a lot of you all probably know it
gives you a ton of flexibility in terms
of like tinkering with different model
types and and like we're getting into
more and I'll pee things for certain
text modeling applications and like
pythons NLP story is really good it
seems like on the scholar side it's a
bit more fractured like spark is there
right we could use spark but sort of and
it's also a story of how this happens a
lot of companies were like stripe was
smaller the team started using Python
from the beginning got very used to
working in Python and like as we hired
more and more people like those people
were used to working in Python so I
think that that's largely it's just like
the engineers like using scikit-learn
because it's really good right so yep
yeah yeah so we're sort of looking like
I think stripes spun up its first
kubernetes cluster this year right
recently I think the future is probably
moving to more like yet container izing
something and shipping and container to
a cluster we're certainly about we're
about to do that with training as far as
serving I'm not sure we haven't talked
about it much we're definitely about to
like move to containers for training
there's like dumb dumping containers at
Cooper Nettie's job and train that way
but we're not quite there yet like on
the actual production side it
answer my questionnaire but you're gold
in time you are if everyone uses Python
there's a little bit of spark now but
it's like a favorite it's like one
person right using spark so everyone
else you despite on yep yep constraining
yeah yeah so we're like we're constraint
now and like developer resources right
because we have to go in and develop
like we need to go in the Scala sign
actually implement this stuff I would
say like our infrastructure is not our
infrastructure is not quite good enough
yet even to like enable tensorflow stuff
on the training side right so it's a
little bit it's a little bit like fixed
on scikit-learn which is not good
and we're moving towards like letting
people to sort of like bring whatever
model you want I think we'll still have
to implement it on the scallop side
luckily with something like deep
learning like diplomat 8 like the
training is hard once you have the
training is the matrix of waste right so
it's a little bit easier to actually
evaluate that thing so the story like
the story for evaluation side is not too
bad we just like implemented an SVM a
couple weeks ago and it actually didn't
take too long
so it wasn't too bad yep ooh good
question I mean the so you're talking
about the actual scoring of the model
itself I mean this this happens for
every transaction that goes through
stripes infrastructure and we have
pretty hard bounds on unlike the late
like latency right how much time we have
returned it's it's like in the hundreds
of milliseconds right so yeah and it has
to happen in real time to like we need
to score transactions in real time it's
really really fast I'm not sure if we've
actually looked at it that closely
compared to scikit-learn because we're
not too worried about it like usually we
just train the model in scikit-learn we
do all the predictions and then the
Scala side so yeah good question but we
have with that too closely
yeah yeah yeah one thing we have talked
about like right now on the scholar side
you know everything gets scored live but
we're actually talking about like having
like it an asynchronous endpoint it's
like there are some cases where you
don't need to score everything live
where you can just run things in batch
or where where the customer the customer
being like the stripe API on the other
end actually doesn't need an immediate
answer back especially so we talked
about like the candidate models like
right now we score the candidate model
at the exact same time that we score the
production model like we don't actually
need to do that right because someone's
just going to go look at that candidate
model like every day or every other day
so that's the sort of thing like we
could move into like a sync batch
scoring that we probably will do in the
future
yep yeah so live traffic does go to the
model but no response is returned we
just log it so it goes to the model I
mean we return the response to the
service that's calling it and then just
log that response so that we can
aggregate it later and say all right we
you know how did this thing do compared
to the to the live production one
yeah no response is actually getting
back to like come getting outside of
stripe infrastructure it's basically
just getting logged any other questions
yep
yes so the question is about features
you have a lot of transformations right
so you saw that and some of these
pipelines can be pretty complex so we
can have like five different
scikit-learn future transformers
whatever so answers yes that when we
ship that model package all the
Transformers are actually shipped as
part of it and in on the scholar side we
basically build like a parallel pipeline
or like alright we've got five
Transformers this thing needs to go
through before it actually hits the
model itself so the answer is yes
other questions yep that is a really
good question and I'm going to be honest
and I'm not so I that is something that
was prob like built before I showed up
but I don't actually have the answer for
you so how do we test that the two that
the two are the same that is a really
good question and one that I'll take
back though because a lot of
infrastructure was built before I came
like the reason I can be somewhat a few
supervisors because I actually didn't
build a lot of it so you my colleagues
did a great job and had some good ideas
so good question I honestly don't know
off Tom ahead all right any other
questions
good yeah so this is this is sort of a
political organization saying and the
stripe is really interested in like not
becoming a massively polyglot
organization it's like really they want
as much stuff in Ruby as they can get in
there right they want more most people
working in Ruby on the data side we do
have a lot of Scala things a lot of
that's because like the JVM has the best
tooling for Hadoop and that sort of
thing
I don't think on an organizational level
like we're super interested in putting
Python services in production I think
that's probably the answer is it like
for training and for actually doing some
of the ML stuff it's fine but if we
start putting servers as production I
think we might get a little bit of side
I I think containerization and
kubernetes could change that a little
bit I think if it's easy to ship a
container and do that sort of thing then
maybe but that's that's largely why it's
just like organizational constraints so
any other questions all right thank you
everybody
[Applause]